Shane Stanley, Filmmaker/Author/Instructor:You
may not think five thousand dollars for a gift
basket is a lot of money for an actor, but
you’re also spending this much at night on
a hotel room and in reality they’re going to
spend 12 hours a day on a set.Film Courage:
Toward the end of your bookWhat You Don’t Learn
in Film School you have this fascinating story
where you saved a Hollywood studio 50 million
[dollars]?Shane:It was for a very large trilogy
that they were producing at the time and what
had happened is they had committed to making
three blockbuster movies (tent polls) over
the course of I think five or six years and
they had tremendous success with the first
one. It was everything that they make these
kind of movies for and more. The second
one had come out and not done very well.
I got a phone call one day from somebody
that I had worked with when I was doing
studio work and I guess he had talked to one of
the heads of production at this other studio and
said you need to kind of flip the script on your
mindset. You really need to get anindie ratto
look at your budget, your schedule and your script
and let somebody go in with the mindset that
understands production at this level but thinks
how do you make something for a dollar really for
a dime. I got a phone call out of the blue one day
and it was a head of production for a studio and
they had me come in they wouldn't talk much about
it on the phone it was very hush-hush and covert
everything was in code and i walked into the
boardroom and there was all these people sitting
around a horseshoe table with you know their fiji
bottles of water and their highlighter pens or
sharpies and their pads of paper and they had a
seat for me and i couldn't figure out why i was
there and you know one of the the head-head people
came in he was wearing a suit i remember that
and um told me the situation and what they
were dealing with and how they had made
really big commitments going into the third that
the second film's lack of success did not justify
they but they were contractually obligated
to certain escalations in people's pay
they were shooting in different countries all
over the world um so they asked if i would um
take a look at the they wanted me to look at
the first two films then they wanted me to break
down the third one just from my perspective
and it was it was heavy cgi you know it was
a big tentpole studio movie it's not what i
do but they had me go through everything and
we spent a few days i had to do everything there i
wasn't allowed to leave with any materials my cell
phone had to be far there was a person in the room
with me at all times and just broke it down and
it's just common sense common sense common sense
and then you know i'd see a way to save you know a
lot of money and they would tell me no you can't
do that because we have this contract in place
or there are these agreements with unions or you
know we have to pay these actors these scales but
it was interesting looking at a budget for a
film that was you know over 200 million dollars
i mean you know when you're making films that
are comfortably you know in that million dollar
range and you know you you find a place for
every dime and you make sure it stretches
and you start looking at where money is going at
dollars at that level it's mind-blowing you
know the money that's spent wasted that'll never
see the screen you know perk packages daily per
diems and bonuses and private jets back and forth
hotels that cost a fortune that these these actors
will be in to just sleep a couple hours you know
a few hours a night um it's mind-blowing and
um so i i felt very fortunate to be a part of
that process it it reminded me of the difference
between being an independent filmmaker and
really being in embedded with the studio system
and this was at a time when when the studios were
just spending so much money and there i don't
think there was a real checks and balances on
where these these dollars were going it was
it's about give the actors what they need
give the filmmakers what they need you know
above the line producers i think there were
17 of them 18 of them that's not including the
talent um you know cinematographers and high-end
crew i mean there were some really big crew
people on this too and this was a big film
and i i think you know looking back that
i don't think anything's changed with them
you know it's no surprise that a studio will
gladly spend 200 million dollars to make 20
million i mean that's obviously not the goal but
that's kind of the business model for a lot of
the studios you know a lot of people say well 80
of studio films fail that's true but what we deem
a failure just because we look at the domestic
box office doesn't mean globally it was a failure
it's a lot of ways that they can still
make money on ancillaries and different
outlets for their project or you know plushies and
toys and all the stuff that come with it but um it
was an interesting experience and it it really
made me appreciate what we do as independent
filmmakers and and why i really i think it was an
experience like that because i just come off of
making gridiron gang shortly before and was lining
up to do some more studio and network projects
and i remember walking away from that and just
saying you know sure who wouldn't want a paycheck
like some of these people were getting of course
we who wouldn't but when it comes down to getting
movies made and loving what you do and who you
do it with and passion for maybe it's your art
passion for working with the people you care about
or just want to kick a movie out every year or two
it really it really kind of helped push me into
the direction of just saying you know what that
that isn't what i want to pursue i want to be
able to find people that want to go get their
hands dirty stretch a buck shoot where we're
not supposed to shoot shoot with cameras that
aren't the newest or the coolest and go make fun
movies that you know people may or may not like
it was kind of a life-changing experience
for me i'm glad we saved the studio a lot
of money i mean it was i couldn't remember it
was 38 or 52. i haven't read that part of the
book in a while but there was we saved them a
lot of money i mean and just common sense money
where was most of the money being
spent that you ended up cutting
um most of the money was um believe it or not
um studios spend an outrageous amount of money
in post-production on films like that and they
have contracts they have ways that they're gonna
put money into something from one account
into another you know that that happens when
you know they'll have three edit bays working
on one film that's a walk and talk drama you
know they can have an apprentice editor setting
things up for the assistant editor the assistant
editor setting up things for the other editor and
the amount of money they're charging for these
these kit fees and these bungalow rentals and
you know there are there are union jobs so
those pay scales are what they are unless you're
getting an academy award winner a real hot editor
but what i notice is just i i know a lot of
veterans i mean editing's my back my background
cgi i've got a lot of people in my life that
do that and when you start budgeting things
and you start getting teams of 30 40 50 people
to do something that you see you know you can
cut this down you don't have to go this route you
could go to a different country you don't have a
contract with this country to do post you can talk
to these guys here they would love your business
and probably cut this most of these things were
done in post and cgi and just kind of reworking
perks i mean it was even you know studios have
their private jets they they perk out you know
and have deals with hotels all over the world
but there's only so many jets to go around so
it was it even got to the point where we were
literally making deals with other private charter
services and other people that we knew in the
private airline business that were able to help
save a lot of money because you know flight from
la to new york people don't realize a private
plane flight could cost over 20 grand it's not a
cheap flight so imagine flying people from la to
other parts of the world and trying to just
connect dots with transportation coordinators that
weren't to bruise any egos but just kind of inform
some of the executives on where they could go
and that's what we did now
how much money they ended up
using on that savings or you know how much
whatever the dollar amount was that we saved i
don't know what they ended up spending i just know
on paper following all their guidelines and rules
and their you know what they asked you know us to
adhere to in putting together a new budget it was
it was pretty substantial you know for all
i know they spent more than that uh than the
original budget they probably did but you know
it checked everything checked out it was doable
and during this meeting were there certain topics
that made them uncomfortable when you said let's
cut this and we'll do this and we'll move this
over here and you could see oh that's that's
probably not going to work for them um there's
a lot of looking around you know what i found in
in a system like that is it there's a pecking
order there is a hierarchy and and is there isn't
most business and a lot of people um when you'd
suggest something you wouldn't get one person
saying yes or no you get a lot of people looking
to one or two different people and then looking to
another person and it just ends up going to
the head of the table anyway you know um so
it's it's rare people are going to go out on
a limb and say that's that's what we need to
do it kind of you know the ideas always played
pinball or would come back after three or four
discussions to a no or hey that's good can
we try this over there and they were very
forward thinking once they started seeing it
wasn't like i reinvented the wheel for them
it was just getting them to just kind of throttle
back a little bit on the hemorrhaging of money on
everything giving everybody everything okay
you have made these commitments to these
actors i get that but they don't need to know
what you're spending on these things these gift
perks these you know hotel rooms or these other
perks that go on that these actors are given
films at that level there's different ways to
to still give them what you're contractually
obligated to give them and save and we were
getting to the point where literally saving
two three hundred dollars on every gift basket
i mean that's that's the kind of stuff we were
literally getting down to we were doing
everything we could to save them money
gift basket so that is a typical thing on certain
sets oh sure sure the studios treat their actors
really well and i i think even independent
filmmakers you know should if they don't when
you get an actor that shows up on your film that's
you know a special guest i think i think welcoming
them with something even if it's a fruit basket
or a bottle of nail polish or something is good
but studios you know they they have some really
you know and there's a lot of sponsorship that
comes with that too it's kind of like the oscars
but there is costs there are you know all sorts of
things that go into these things that cost money
everything costs money and you know when you start
going in with the mindset of okay instead of just
saying you're going to spend five thousand dollars
on every gift basket and it's going to end up
costing you 2500 to 3 500 after you get the free
how do you make them feel equally special for
five or six hundred dollars and it's it's doable
it's just about taking the time to break it down
and not just throwing the money at the problem
sure and then you said the hotel room where
they may just stay over well yeah unfortunately
there wasn't a lot we could do with hotel rooms
because of contracts you know various studios and
production entities you know especially when
studios are going to other parts of the world
there are a lot of setups already so they're not
going to you're not going to go in and ruffle too
many feathers with that but it's just the cost
and it's reminding them that you may not think
five thousand dollars for a gift basket is a lot
of money for an actor but you're also spending
this much at night on a hotel room and in reality
they're going to spend 12 12 hours a day on a set
then they're going to be doing this this this
press junket maybe this and at the end of the day
this is with the exception of their days off this
is where they're going to hang their head at night
and how how can some of these things be worked
out and i think most of those things were kind of
finagled more for not the top tier level of
actor but it was about finding other similar
accommodations that were substantially lower
i mean it's it's not rocket surgery i mean
i've got i've got a nephews getting married at
pebble beach coming up and they threw us all
the available hotels and i mean i think the room
started 1200 1400 a night and you know those two
things i don't pay for myself is a nice fancy
hotel room and a first-class airfare you know
i'm just sitting on a plane going from a to
b i'll do a coach i have no problem with that
um i made three phone calls and i i i'm basically
five minutes from the wedding spending 209
a night for the wedding that's just the mentality
that i have you know i just think there's money
that is better served somewhere else and and so i
that's the mentality i kind of took with them and
everything and um you know they were receptable
to a lot of the ideas again did they end up doing
it i know i wasn't leaving until i was able to
show them a savings so they at least accepted
what i presented at the end of the day but i i
couldn't tell you what they ended up spending
you never know but i know that they were they
were concerned going in and needed needed some
cuts so i i don't think they just brought
me in to have me warm a seat for three days
well i don't want to blow my street
cred here but what is an indie rat
i'm an indie rat it's people that just you know
they don't wait for the machine they figure out a
way you know it's i i always you know i talk about
in the book is you know give me an actor a camera
and a place to do it and let's go make a movie
it's it's not waiting for a machine to decide you
know when all the stars align you know i had when
we did gridiron gang we made that deal i believe
in 1993 it was the most sought after property in
hollywood everybody had bid on it but paramount
and you know hundreds of producers directors
and actors all wanted to be a part of it and
then it gets to the studio and it took two years
to finally go into turnaround it never got made
and you know fast forward to 2006 you know and i
just i know not every film goes through that but
it's not uncommon and i had spent some time at a
network after doing gridiron i i was brought on
uh to to develop in-house projects for a major
network with a writing partner of mine at the
time and we spent i think 13 months there talking
about a lot of great projects that never got made
and these were passion projects that the network
wanted to do these weren't our ideas it was we
were brought in to do the passion projects that
the high ups wanted to see get made and the
meetings and the development discussions and i'll
never forget it you know um the the vp of the the
network brought me into his office one day after
our 100th you know development meeting on one show
and it was friday and he said you like scotch i
said i like scotch he poured us a scotch we put
our feet up on his coffee table and shot
the breeze for a few minutes and he said
you're a filmmaker man you don't belong here he
said i can see your frustration he said i he's
you'll always have an open door with me but i
think you need to just go out and make movies
he goes this isn't how you work i said yeah i
just don't understand it i said we've been here
13 months we've gone from this project for four
months to oh that's not cool anymore let's jump on
this one oh that's that's not gonna fit in today's
climate and then we go to something else and i
said here we're on round three in 13 months and we
haven't done anything i said you know my idea is
write something that you're excited about get some
friends together and go shoot it and that's that's
what i do that's what i believe in and um i think
at that point i had just gotten to in my life was
where it was about just just doing what we wanted
to do and it doesn't agree with everybody and not
everybody likes what i do and that's not why i
don't do it for people who like it i do it because
i need to do it to just to feel alive that's
you know what i need to do and um it's it's been
it's been a lot of fun and and i wouldn't trade
those days in doing the studio film or you know
working with the networks the way i did it it
taught me so much to be able to do what i do today
because i can see it from both sides i can see it
from a creative person who doesn't have a lot of
budget to work with but i also know the end game
in when this thing is done where it has to go how
it how it has to be exploited around the world
and making sure we check the boxes that you know
all 54 territories and 172 countries that are
out there that buy there's something in it for
everybody how can the quote-unquote indie rats and
the quote-unquote suits harmoniously work together
because each needs each other each needs each
other that's a that is a great question um i wish
i had all the answers and i i'd like to think
i play well with others i some of the greatest
relationships i've had in this town have been with
the suits um and i p what people we all have to
remember this is a business at the end of the day
but it's like let's take something like the car
business which we talked about before you have the
people that actually design the cars that you know
have jobs designing and engineering then you have
the people that actually have to be the executives
behind the decision to greenlight a car being made
and then you have the car dealerships that are
going to acquire the cars and then you have the
salesmen who have to sell them and then you got
the mechanics who have to work on them everybody
needs each other it's kind of like on a film set
we have a rule where i don't care if you're the
star of the show if you're a pa you're all equal
to this machine running in in harmony and we all
need to show respect for one another and i think
i think there's always been a little bit of a
clash between the suits and the the filmmaker
but i think if if people can get on the same page
and i think i think if the executives would trust
the artist that they're giving their money to or
distributing i think if you fall in love with
an idea you fall in love with the script or a
filmmaker's vision from a previous film you
need to decide i either trust this person
to run with it or i don't and i think
when you get too many cooks in the kitchen
i think it stifles the creativity i i know i've
been involved with some pretty pretty big projects
where the suits and the artists couldn't ever
get along it got very very intense it got it got
explosive at times even on sets where a studio
exactly show up not happy with the director
for a style they're shooting in or unhappy because
a dp is moving the camera too much and the the
tempers that flare on set in front of everybody
i mean you know we are in a industry of children
whether we like it or not um and i just i just
don't think it needs to be that way and i think
communication is key it's not just okay we believe
in you you're getting paid go shoot this movie
and then we look at dailies and we tell you what
we like and don't like and when you start doing
that to an artist it really the hair on the back
of their neck goes up i've seen it time and time
again and i just think there's i think there's
probably some basic fundamentals i find a lot of
suits spend a lot of time psychoanalyzing things
they take a lot of classes and body language
how to read somebody's temperament
across the desk or across the room
and i don't think they've been taught or maybe
there isn't a class maybe when you make this
the next book is basically how to understand the
inner workings of an artist and what those buttons
are in their life that can make them because
once that trust has been broken or once that
that communication has been derailed i i it's very
i don't think it's something that can come back
did it do the steeple you know with the
hands a lot of this i'm not talking like this
thinking am i doing that right now no no i'm
just i'm just thinking of like you know the
any any good uh movie with an executive or
something you'll have the steeple and they'll
be thinking watch phil watch phil joanna's
film entropy i think it's a brilliant film
phil phil's a friend uh he directed great
aaron gang um you know phil it's no secret
phil punched out a studio executive in front
of 300 people on a set of heaven's prisoner
and um i think he was heaven's prisoner he did um
it was the alec baldwin film and you watch what
builds to that point and a lot of people don't
believe that actually happened i can assure you
it did um and it happens more often than you
realize it may not go to blows as much anymore
i think people are ready for that now or they they
hide behind text and emails is really what people
are able to do it's that's also a lot of the
face-to-face has been taken out of our business
everything's text messaging and emails and you
know i think a lot of people do that out of
trying to get it done quick fear and fear is a
big big component of that because people don't
like confrontation and i think you know if
executives would just understand that when
you trust an artist's vision and you greenlight
him or her to to fulfill that promise that you
you really need to just trust you you know sidney
lumet in his book said something brilliant about
hiring actors and he said when you're a
director and you make a decision on an actor
good or bad you have to live with that decision
and you have to do everything you can to see that
that journey is as smooth as sailing as
possible i can't remember the words he used but
there were times in his career where he said
that he really thought he had the right actor
for a role and realized on day one in rehearsal
that this was the biggest mistake of his life and
you would never know it as an audience member
you would never know it as maybe the actor who
he hired but it's it's about understanding the
being that you're working with and artists are
fragile we're very sensitive to everything we take
everything personally you know if somebody doesn't
like a cut or somebody doesn't like you know the
theme of something or the style it's it's it's
a personal attack it's never separated and it
takes a strong artist to be able to do that and
i think it takes a stronger executive to be able
to really find a way to communicate with people
on how to get the adjustments the studio
or network might need to get what they need
and i i've really seen it done in a productive
way that's just me sure and i agree with what
you're saying about being sensitive but i think
also too some of the quote unquote suits and i
wish i could find a better word for them but um
they're also sensitive in that they don't like
being told no and they don't like people usurping
their authority or or challenging them especially
if they believe in this pecking order and there's
a lot of fear i think there's fear from both you
know what hollywood fear and love okay so so fear
fear from both sides and so just thinking about
what are ways that you know there could we could
prevent a blow up if if one is mirrored in a
pecking order mindset and well i can't believe
you would tell me what to do you don't you know
who i am and then there's this artist don't
you know what i've done and i can't believe
you would doubt me and then the clash that happens
yeah and it's ego driven at the end of the day i
mean it's fear driven and it's ego driven because
you know in our business it's it's literally you
know your career could be made or broken in in one
project you're either the next damian chazelle or
you know you make a mistake and you don't
have a hit you're done i mean you know
look what happened to uh george casamatos you
know he came off of god rest him he was a great
filmmaker i mean look at what tombstone he did
tombstone and he was you know the next greatest
thing and i worked with him on shadow conspiracy
with charlie sheen which was i think the last film
he ever did and i can assure you that's not what
he wanted to go six feet under with his name on
and i don't think he would have worked much after
that film no disrespect but not saying i could do
anything better i'm just saying when you look
at how fast you can turn around you know um
you know some great filmmakers and actors in this
industry that have hits that people just they're
just bowled over with and they do a couple more
films and what happens to them and it's unfair
you know one of my favorite filmmakers of all time
is mike figgis i mean i admire him because here's
a guy who writes directs produces edits composes
caters you know probably cleans the latrine
i mean that guy is a filmmaker's filmmaker and
obviously when he had leaving las vegas with you
know nicholas cage and elizabeth shu and all the
oscar accolades that came with it how do you deny
somebody like that you know this guy's gonna do
it again you know solomon king went through the
same thing you know he had a string of hits and
then had some that that weren't as successful and
you know and um it's it's you know i guess it's
like that in sports it's like that in in a lot
of businesses i mean i don't know it seems like
people can in the suit side it seems like people
can run companies into the ground over and over
again and still end up running other companies but
we see that a lot but i think i think the artists
and the executives i think need to find a way
to to spend more time understanding one another
and not just thinking they understand one another
you know we forget that you know i always go
back to the record industry and and you know
when when music was you know a business back in
the earlier days of a r representatives working
for labels and seeking bands and clubs that
nobody heard of and watching that that machine
grow into becoming something that was worthy of
signing to a major label i knew a lot of a r guys
back in the 80s and 90s because of my music
background and i used to say to them you know
how do you not get fired and they said we say
no you don't sign a ban you don't get fired
and studios have to crank out so many films
a year production companies have to fulfill
the machine especially now because it's a
bottomless pit right you know if you know how
many productions are getting made at netflix
at any given time it's 33 i think right now
so there's a machine that needs to be filled
but i think they understand each other
from a very generic standpoint i still
don't think they've found a way to really
melt into you know harmonious relationships
it's very rare it's very rare.
Question
For The Viewers:
What was the most surprising part of this video?